au cimetière de granby règne une
mystérieuse ambiance un peu comme si on
avait le sentiment d'être sans cesse
observée au détour des tombes une
immense roche attire mon attention
en créant les brownies palmer cox a
légué un héritage inestimable aux
enfants mais qu'ils étaient ceux palmer
cox et de quel héritage
s'agissait-il balma costes a été un
écrivain illustrateur et poète qui a été
connue surtout pour être l'auteur des
brownies des personnages qui ont eu un
immense succès au tour des années 1880 à
1920 l'église c'est des créatures
magiques imaginaire qui sont issus du
folklore écossais qui différencie les
brownies des autres créatures magiques
cas c'est leur serviabilité l'envers les
hommes et ont des pouvoirs magiques et
ils craignent la lumière du jour donc il
sort juste la nuit pour accomplir leur
tâche et il se montrait jamais aux mains
les balises sont vraiment caractérisée
par une curiosité qui est presque une
curiosité enfantine et grâce à leur
curiosité donc les bonnes listes vont
explorer le monde qui est en changement
à cause de nombreuses découvertes
techniques et scientifiques là ici sont
aux prises avec le téléphone avec ses
livres illustrés ces personnages aussi
fantasque que sympathique
palmer cox était loin de se douter qu'il
allait créer un tel engouement auprès
des jeunes qu'on parlera de brownies
magna il a publié une quinzaine d'albums
des brownies et en 1924
on a calculé qu'il y aurait eu un
million des copies vendues lors du
passage du vent ni même comment
l'appeler à dans une ville comme
étiquette il y aurait eu 20 mille
enfants qui seraient réunies pour venir
l'accueillir pour souligner son passage
par le maire cox dessiner ce brownies
dans son bureau situé à broadway la
popularité des brownies va être tels que
les entreprises toutes sortes vont
vouloir associer leur nom assez curieux
personnage il ya eu une variété
impressionnante d'objets ya eu de la
vaisselle aïeux des tapis des objets
pour les enfants eux-mêmes du papier
peint
[Musique]
et l'appareil photo la fameuse blick am
raoui et qu'il est peut-être l'objet le
plus connu qui porte le nom de brownies
pour lequel là on sait avec certitude
que par le maroc n'avait pas donné son
consentement
il ya eu des pièces de théâtre qui ont
été tirées de ces personnages là ce qui
ont aussi contribué à les faire
connaître
pas seulement aux états-unis au canada
et même en angleterre
certains n'ont pas hésité à comparer le
génial illustrateur à lewis carroll
l'auteur d'alice au pays des merveilles
qui a autant traverser les frontières
que les esprits mais d'autres pensent
avant tout au père de mickey on pourrait
peut-être le comparer à walt disney
pourri l'idée originale de trouver des
personnages qui avait pas été exploitée
à 20 avec son travail artistique qui a
su les transformer pour qu'il plaise
vraiment aux enfants après son passage
triomphal aux états unis il va revenir à
granby où il fera bâtir en 1906 le
château brownie qui avaient des enfants
qui allaient le visiter régulièrement
pour revoir ses dessins les amener en
haut de sa tour où il y avait
apparemment un drapeau avec un brownie
est devenu le père des brownies il est
mort à gwatt be à 84 ans en 1924
[Musique]
sa maison le château brownie existe
toujours mais ses personnages
est ce qu'il existe un char en hausse
j'en ai pas encore eu la preuve mais
sûrement que dans l'imaginaire des gens
il existe et si on va se promener dans
le château des brownies pensez vous
qu'on va être observée et pied ça se
pourrait
[Musique]